The jogan Experience so you were saying
that you're on the fence off the fence
about grush the story I was hearing is
it's just it's a it's a lot and with I'm
going to skip a lot of it but what I was
reading and SL what they were saying is
that one possibility that could be going
on is there is
an I think we're taking in some of gram
Hancock stuff too if if people were
around on Earth 500,000 years ago in
some way there was some split in a
second set of humans continued on and
we're like in this inter Dimension space
where they're both happening
simultaneously and that's where like if
he was saying this no no no no this is
from the I'm gathering this all from
like that video I'm adding in some M gr
Hancock stuff too because this kid
didn't also interviewed him Jesse
Michaels on his on his podcast they're
talking about some of the same stuff but
something they said in the grush
interview on his podcast was that uh an
idea would be that these people exist on
a on like a split
uh timeline from us like we had
cataclysms and died and repopulated and
whatnot now we've ended in this place in
20123 with combustion engines and
were're flying around these people would
have been in a different anti-gravity
who knows what they figured out and they
went somewhere else I think I don't
they're not even saying that this is
where like they're not going to talk I
they haven't talked about that but I
think what they're saying or getting or
getting at maybe is that they're here
and that's why the nuclear thing is so
um
uh important to them they're on the same
Planet as us and if we blow up the
planet it goes away from so they're here
we just don't know where they are and
that's where the in dimension thing
comes in I that's what I'm gathering out
of what I've heard how high were you
when you came up with this it's not I
don't think I'm saying it's my theory
this is what they're sort of saying and
gush is sort of like that's an
interesting thing you're saying he's not
confirming it with him or anything but
it was it's a lot to take in that's
definitely for sure yeah it's all a lot
to take in we David grush is that UFO
whistleblower the testifying front of
Congress yeah it's hard to say man the
thing about it is I believe he's telling
the truth as far as what he's experience
and the documents that he uncovered and
the people that he talked to but how do
you know whether or not they're just
using him as a useful idiot to just get
out some silly story because they're
covering up for the fact that there's
some very Advanced drone system that the
United States government has they're
trying to keep under wraps right it
might be both I I think it's probably
both things you well here's the
thing you're out in the woods all the
time mhm you ever see a UFO no ever see
Bigfoot no have you ever talked to a
hunter that's seen a UFO no ever talked
to a hunter that's seen Bigfoot I talked
to so really the guys down at San Carlos
the Apache reservation yeah they said
they've seen stuff okay were they on
peyote I don't know cuz I know a lot of
those Indians get down I don't think so
I mean I don't and it's been like
multiple times what kind of St Stu like
square like something Square flying oh
interesting yeah because that is the
thing that they describe right it's a
square with a sphere inside of it like a
black no the opposite a sphere with a
black Square inside of it for field or
something I always [__] that yeah so
that's I don't know anybody other than
that that's a that's the first story
I've heard from somebody who I have
talked to well that kind of makes sense
that that thing they do spot that's a
common
one some flying Square inside a sphere
like a translucent sphere and that's uh
like legitimate Pilots have seen that
that's a weird one right is that my
theory and this is totally unfounded
without any research whatsoever it's
just those are the best kind these are
my favorite kind of theories my theory
is that they have this ability to make
something move in this insane way with
gravity but they can't put a body in it
and and they can't put weapons in it
they can't it's just an object that they
can get to move at insane rates of speed
that's what I think I think the military
applications of this thing have yet to
be figured out but I think they do have
something that can do things that we
have no knowledge of but the United
States government is
probably they probably have in their
possession something that was either
back engineered from something from
somewhere else or something that they
developed in a completely top secet
environment with the top research
scientist probably during the wars
during World War II and three or three
uh Vietnam that's impending and in Iraq
and Afghanistan you think about the
amount of money that gets funel funnel
through the government and that they
they don't I mean didn't the Pentagon
just for the sixth year in a row fail
their audit imagine you failed your
audit 6 years old boy they crawl up your
ass with a [__] microscope yeah I
think is that what it was they ever
passed it but yeah is correct that to
say fail six audit with
number passing so there's a lot of money
flowing around is my point yeah and who
knows how much of that money is going to
these secret programs that we don't know
about yeah yeah I know and if they did
that and they did have the top scientist
and if I was the [__] president and I
was the chief of staff and I was running
Pentagon I would want the best scientist
so I'd recruit the best scientist and
I'd said hey you know this is National
Security we're working on this project
it uses gravity propulsion shut the [__]
up don't tell anybody but you get to
work on some cool [__] yeah and you get
make paid a lot of money you get paid a
lot of money and you get to be a part of
one of the most insane discoveries in
human history so this is what we're
working on yeah I think that's likely
too but then you got to go back to like
the Foo Fighters from the 1940s and the
crash at well and that you also have to
be open to the possibility that like
look there's a lot of planets out there
MH lot of planets out there it's very
possible that we're not
alone